Court proceedings progressing for the
two of Las Vegas women facing charges in
a crash that killed two toddlers thank
you for joining us at four I'm Kirsten
Joyce and I'm Brian Loftus the driver of
that vehicle was in North Las Vegas
justice court this morning that crash
happening more than three weeks ago near
Lone Mountain and Clayton right Matthew
joins us in studio with today's update
Ryan yeah Brian and Kirsten renisha
Washington posted a 25 thousand dollar
bill prior to Christmas documents show
she was the passenger in that crash as
well as the mother of those two toddlers
the driver is her sister Khalia Manning
she's still in jail but the judge sliced
her bail in half while her attorneys say
she denies almost everything
25-year-old Khalia Manning rolled into
North Las Vegas Justice Court for the
second time in a month stop touching the
child She's accused of driving with more
than double the Nevada blood alcohol
limit while her two toddler nieces sat
improperly restrained in the back the
car slammed into a tree and the toddlers
died
her attorneys Dan Winder and Arnold
Weinstock asked for a reduced bail
citing her immobility due to the crash
injuries and her willingness to quote
prove her innocence
they cite concerns with the car's power
steering but to the DA's office
Clark County Deputy district attorney Yu
Ming citing Manning's prior criminal
history as reasons to keep her in
custody
polymers die what kind of assurance is
with that history of the decision-making
process assures this community that this
defendant is going to make a good a good
decision wow how do I know she's gonna
come back if she's released despite
those concerns of Judge Natalie Tyrell
she sliced Manning's bail from a hundred
thousand to fifty thousand dollars on
the condition she remains on house
arrest with high-level electronic
monitoring it's not over until it's over
and we're in the process of
preparing our case and trying to bolster
our position as a state obviously is
going to try to bolster their position
but that's what court support
now the preliminary hearing was pushed
back nearly two months the state will
then determine if there's enough
evidence to go to trial that includes
examining the crashing vehicle both
North Las Vegas Police and a private
mechanic professional they're examining
it together before the next state and by
the way the family of the two toddlers
say they will be laid to rest tomorrow
Kirsten
thank you very much Ryan he did mention
that Manning's criminal history includes
hoarding a police officer during a high
school fight in 2016. now the attorney
wants to let people know for the family
that they are wanting against donating
to online fundraisers saying there's no
guarantee the family will get that money
as no official fundraisers have been
created Brian